Збройні сили Росії не атакують житлові
будинки та об'єкти цивільної
інфраструктури таке заявляв прессекретар
Кремля Дмитро пісков
[музика]
над користувачі поширювали інформацію що
українська військова робила селфі з
трупами російських військових і
надсилала їх матерям загиблих а
президент Росії Володимир Путін
стверджував що при владі їй в армії
України нацисти країни
це Лише кілька із безлічі фальшивих
тверджень у цій тривалій війні
Росія вторглася в Україну рік тому
відтоді загинули щонайменше понад 7
тисяч мирних українських громадян
Путін сподівається Підкорити Україну і
його режим використовує для цього
спеціальну зброю дезінформацію
мета демонізувати ворога та узаконити
війну
які нарадиви використовує Росія як
працюють компанії з дезінформації і яку
дезінформацію поширює українська сторона
розгляньмо детальніше почнімо спочатку
24 лютого 2022 року Росія напала на
Україну
і ось як це виправдав Путін
атлантического Альянс і начавшиеся
военное своение территории Украины для
нас неприємним чи справді в Україні були
Розгорнуті війська НАТО як натякав Путін
ні Україна не є членом Альянсу а це
необхідна умова для розміщення На її
території військ НАТО
Путін не зміг надати жодних доказів
важливо показати наскільки вона
насправді в небезпеці оточена як їй
загрожує Україна
тому вона має захищатися а війна є не
більше ніж обороною
затвердження не нове Росія часто
стверджувала що на неї нападають це був
перший великий дезінформаційний наратив
цієї війни
Я б сказав що Це почалося з Євромайдану
чи Революції гідності у 2014 році
відтоді росіяни почали стверджувати що
захід втручається в Україну
клінічна Атлантичний альянс дотримувався
основоположного акту Росія НАТО 1997
року який забороняє додаткове постійне
розгортання бойових сил у країнах котрі
сподіваються приєднатися до Альянсу але
якщо до поставок зброї вони не означають
що країна стає стороною конфлікту
про це свідчать висновки аналітиків
німецької бундестагу та Конгресу США
засновані на правових оцінках різних
експертів
однак цей дезінформаційний наратив досі
має вплив
дослідження в Німеччині показало 19
відсотків німців погодилися ствердженням
що НАТО настільки довго провокували
Росію що Москва була змушена розпочати
війну 5 частина опитуваних частково з
цим погодилися загалом 40% німців
частково вірять цьому наративу
ба більше Під час цієї війни Росія
розкручувала тезу про злий захід
Раф стверджувало що НАТО і захід винні в
глобальному дефіциті продовольства
зокрема у нестачі пшениці
захід зображується як Тригер так би
мовити дефіциту прибутків харчування
який дійсно існує
не тільки за межами ЄС але і певною
мірою всередині ЄС
де звісно знову замислюється про
доцільність санкцій
сьогоднішній день бетафе але факти
говорять про інше за даними Європейської
ради експорт української пшениці впав на
90% після Вторгнення
в основному через російську морську
блокаду тоді дефіцит пшениці призвів до
зростання цін у всьому світі Але хто
поширює дезінформацію як еволюціонувала
Пропаганда варто ще раз пояснити що
дезінформаційна кампанія Росії почалася
задовго до її вторгнення
дезінформація почалася не 24 лютого а
триває роками її цілі дуже добре
визначення
давайте подивимося на головних дійових
осіб російський державні змії російські
політики свідомо поширюють дезінформацію
про війну в Україні
російський депутат в ефірі державного
телебачення заявив що в Україні воюють
війська НАТО точніше польський Спецназ
однак він не надав жодних доказів
у соцмережах з'явився нібито наказ про
мобілізацію польських військ але аналіз
показав що цей документ створений у
Фотошопі
коли в Європейському Союзі та інших
країнах заблокували російські державні
ЗМІ РФ знайшла інші способи поширення
інформації з'явилися нові джерела
дезінформації яка поширюється самою
владою верхівкою по всьому світу
російський посольства та Міністерства
поширюють оману та дезінформацію
наприклад
У нас є
конкретна інформація
щодо тих закладів в Україні теж наукових
інститутів які мають технології що
дозволяють зробити брудну бомбу садить
вот эту саму грязную бомбу брудна бомба
тобто радіоактивна
погляньмо на докази представлені МЗС
Росії
на цьому знімку нібито зображено
розробку брудної бомби дивно однак те що
на сумках напис не українською а
словенською за допомогою зворотного
пошуку зображення ми знайшли слобенське
агентство ядерних відходів арао І
з'ясували що на фотографії зображені
звичайні детектори диму
наше дослідження також виявило що
зображення об'єкти де Україна нібито
створювала брудну бомбу насправді
реактори в Росії
Окей Утім не лише російський урядовці
поширюють фейки блогери і лідери думок
також є частиною цієї пропагандистської
кампанії
згідно з дослідженнями російським
інфлюенцем платили за те щоб вони
поширювали пропаганду серед своїх
підписників і вони часто навіть не
змінювали формулювання
телеграм використовується в усьому світі
для розповсюдження фейкової інформації
оскільки контентна платформі практично
нецензурується і не видаляється також
існують навіть фейкові веб-сайти
перевірки фактів наприклад сайт війна з
фейками він офіційно не пов'язаний з
російським урядом мала безперечно бо
схвалений російським офіційними особами
російськими громадськими діячами звісно
велику роль відіграють анонімні
користувачі та Боти до того ж не лише
Російський уряд та росіяни поширюють
проросійську пропаганду
це також люди які симпатизують Росії
Зазвичай вони вірять у теорії змови
налаштовані проти заходу США і вони
дійсно готові ділитися тим що поширюють
росіяни
прихильники Росії також відіграли
важливу роль у поширенні другого
основного наративу цієї інформаційної
війни того що українці погані люди що
вони нацисти безсовісні та навіть
інсценують власні страждання
як приклад такого наративу розгляньмо
цей пост який нещодавно почав
поширюватися в соцмережах
стверджується що нібито українська
військова Лілія Євтушенко робила селфі з
трупами військових і надсилала їх
матерям загиблих
піксельна ділянка на фото нібито
приховує трупи а Євтушенко начебто
заарештували 18 січня
але звичайний пошук показує що заява
фальшива використовуючи зворотний пошук
зображення ми з'ясували що оригінальну
фотографію опублікувала жінка на ім'я
Олександра Самсонова майже за рік до
початку війни і Це фото було підробленим
на оригінальній світлині немає тіла а
піксельна ділянка приховує лише суху
траву
метою таких фейків також є відвернення
уваги від власних дій Росії у цій війні
нападів на мирне населення України та
можливих військових злочинів знову і
знову
проблематично в цих стратегіях
дезінформації Так це не миттєвий
короткостроковий ефект а вплив який вони
мають довгостроковій перспективі
що частіше повторюється Інформація що
частіше її бачать то більше шансів що
вона запам'ятається людям і це одна з
найважливіших цілей тих хто поширює
дезінформацію
[музика]
ще один відомий приклад обстріл
пологового будинку в українському місті
Маріуполь в березні 2022 року під час
якого загинули Щонайменше троє людей
фотографії пораненої вагітної жінки
стали вірусними але російський урядові
установи заперечували будь-яку
причетність до нападу й стверджували що
лікарня більше не працює та
використовувалася Україною у військових
цілях
це було явно неправдою є багато доказів
нищівної російської атаки наприклад у
звіті ОБСЄ
ще один приклад який шокував світ Буча
понад 450 тіл загиблих виявили в
передмісті Києва
були оприлюднені жахливі кадри які
свідчили про застосування тортур але
російський урядовці заперечували масові
вбивства
це все вигадка це використовується лише
для переривання переговорів
численні користувачі соцмереж
стверджували що масові вбивства в Бучі
постановочні а тіла не справжні оскільки
на відео видно як одна рука рухається
однак як показав наш аналіз цей нібито
рух руки насправді був краплею води на
лобовому склі автомобіля
шокує що докази дуже чіткий докази
надані журналістами з місця подій
настільки нахабно відкидалися
торік ми не раз спостерігали таке
перекручування фактів
ось інший більш свіжий приклад
у середині січня в житловий будинок у
Дніпрі влучила ракета загинули
щонайменше 44 людини
речник Кремля Дмитро пісков звинуватив
Україну
Збройні сили Росії не атакують житлові
будинки чи об'єкти цивільної
інфраструктури він припустив що саме ППО
України спричинила руйнування понад 200
квартир у будинку деякі користувачі
соцмереж навіть стверджували що Україна
зробила Це щоб призвести до ескалації
конфлікту і отримати більше зброї Від
заходу
Росія знову не надала жодних доказів але
Міністерство оборони Великої Британії
оприлюднило аналіз згідно з яким будівлю
в Дніпрі швидше за все знищили російські
ракети х22
[музика]
російська стратегія створення плутанини
щодо того що є правдою А щоб брехнею під
час війни стала більш витонченою
особливо добрий ілюструє третій і
головний наратив який полягає в тому що
західні ЗМІ брешуть
Ми також бачили багато сфабрикованих
новинних повідомлень коли в соцмережах
поширювалися фейкові відео з логотипами
надійних медіа
було Під прицілом і bbcnn На мою думку
це особливо тривожно адже такі відео
виглядають досить переконливо
десь у стратегію можна пов’язати з
четвертим і останнім великим
проросійським наративом демонізацією
українських біженців це відео нібито
створене Deutsche Welle і нібито показує
злочинця біженця з України стверджується
що Петро Савченко шантажував десятки
німкень і погрожував оприлюднити їхні
порнографічні фотографії зняті
прихованою камерою крім того поліція
нібито перевіряє Савченко якому зараз
загрожує ув'язнення це відео фейк його
створила зовсім не Deutsche Welle про це
свідчать розбіжності у шрифті та дизайні
крім того звинувачення були повністю
сфабриковані федеральне управління
кримінальної поліції Німеччини
повідомило що йому невідомо про таке
правопорушення після того як люди почали
виїжджати з України після російського
вторгнення почастішали спроби
дискредитації біженців
неправдиві повідомлення про ні злочини
чи напади які приписували біженцям
неправдиво стверджувалося що біженці є
розповсюджувачами хвороб їх як правило
зображали як небезпечних людей або як
невдячних не цивілізованих чи як
нацистів
один окремий випадок який я пам'ятаю
особливо тривожний трапився в Польщі Це
була неправдива новина про те що дітей
які хворіють на онкологію вигнали з
польської лікарні щоб звільнити місце
для чотирьох українців
[музика]
як бачимо військові атаки Росії на
Україну супроводжується величезною
кампанією з дезінформації російські
пропагандистські неративи повторюються
посилюється та розвиваються далі а як
щодо української сторони
ми дійсно виявили деякі інформаційні
повідомлення які були про українськими
або антиросійськими звісно їх було не
так багато як заяв російського уряду про
українські заяви які ми бачили мале
тенденцію перебільшувати успіх
української армії
одним із прикладів є те як повідомляють
про кількість загиблих у деяких випадках
українські офіційні особи наводять
значно більшу кількість загиблих
російських солдатів ніж наприклад США
ООН і ймовірно У них є на те причини на
війні часто складно встановити дані про
втрати оскільки обидві сторони
зловживають ними в пропагандистських
цілях
ще один відомий приклад спочатку
повномасштабного вторгнення привид Києва
вважалося що цей нібито винятковий Пілот
винищувач сам збив близько 40 російських
літаків
відеоролики українського льотчика
облетіли мережу
проте за нашими висновками привида Києва
швидше за все ніколи не існувало він був
міфом
деякі проукраїнський користувачі пішли
далі в поширенні дезінформації ось
наприклад Володимир Путін нібито
проголошує мир з Україною
тобто створений за допомогою штучного
інтелекту
на кадрах записана промова яка була
виголошена перед початком війни але
звукова доріжка була змінена оригінальне
відео Можна знайти за зворотним пошуком
зображення Якщо порівняти обидва відео
можна наприклад помітити абсолютно
однаковий рух руки в одній точці Отже
фейки з українського боку є але
проросійської пропаганди набагато більше
і вона більш агресивна
ба більше якщо Україна хоче мотивувати
насамперед власне населення То Росія має
зовсім іншу мету звинуватити Україну та
захід у війні яку розпочав Володимир
Путін
[музика]
Я думаю що це стосується виправдання
російського вторгнення в Україну
якщо вони звинувачують когось іншого то
нібито не відповідають за власну
поведінку
звинувачувати треба на нас а українців
НАТО американців європейські уряди тощо
[музика]
рік тому Росія почала війну в Україні ми
досі не знаємо скільки жертв Вона
забрала але знаємо що правда була однією
з перших